[Music]
first things first check your email oh I
got one fake Dylan at WH o this is WH o
real domain right WH int yeah so fake
Dylan is a internet security researcher
that I worked with to send all of our
emails a bunch of fake messages and he
was able to send these messages from the
real w-h-o domain to you from my new job
in the World Health Organization I spent
all my money moving to Geneva
Switzerland
it might say this is a joke in our
example here but this more serious ones
would be like there's an urgent new
coronavirus warning from you know the wh
o as the number of coronavirus cases
increases so to do internet scams and
hoaxes real looking emails supposedly
from the World Health Organization and
CDC asking for money these agencies do
not ask for direct donations by email if
you click on a link or download an
attachment from those emails you could
be giving hackers your personal
information so what we're looking at
here is domain spoofing and we're seeing
a lot with respect to corona virus in
particular so this really has been
totally unprecedented the the teams have
never seen anything like this in terms
of a single lure uniting all different
types of actors behind a single real
pretext for people to do all kinds of
things whether it's actually just steal
their password what we call credential
phishing whether its installed malware
so this is just one example sent from
what looks like a w-h-o email address
just like the one that came to you
clearly it's trying to get you to
download a specific file that they have
sent and researchers at IBM found that
this attachment contains malware that
captures screenshots and logs or
keystrokes and steals usernames and
passwords
beware of criminals pretending to be WH
oh so they've published guidance on this
and they are aware that this is
happening but it's top advice
it's number one advice is verify the
sender by checking their email address
we know that that's pretty easy to fake
at this point
wow I'm surprised they don't point that
out because people might think that if
it has a WH int address that means it's
legitimate but really it's it's like
necessary but not a sufficient condition
correct yeah what I found super
interesting was that we tried spoofing a
bunch of domains and only some of them
went through to the inbox so the CDC and
the Vox emails didn't but the w-h-o and
the Whitehouse gov email is did and I
should say it was only the Yahoo emails
that we set up the Gmail and outlook
emails both put them in spam so I've
been looking into this and it seems like
the greater context around this is that
when email was created back in the 80s
no one bothered to make any way to
verify that the sender is who they say
they are really it is the foundational
technologies of the Internet being built
with no security in mind and no central
database of who is who that gives rise
to this problem and since then there
have been lots of attempts to sort of
build this sort of verification system
the problem is just that the
participation is not as high as it
should be sort of makes sense of this it
might help to think about another type
of verification problem which is that
society doesn't want teenagers to get
into bars to buy alcohol to prevent that
from happening we need two things we
need a way to verify ages which is our
ID system and we need businesses to then
check for IDs now imagine if that ID
system was voluntary so you have a bunch
of adults who might not bother to go get
an ID then when they come to the bar the
business basically has a decision to
make either they require IDs knowing
full well that plenty of legitimate
adults don't have one or to avoid
pissing people off they just let them in
and maybe they end up letting in some
kids too and probably every bar is gonna
make a slightly different decision
that's kind of where we're at with the
email authentication right now we have
an ID system it's called Demark but it's
voluntary so if an email comes in with
my email address
jostad box comm the email service
whether that's Yahoo or Outlook or Gmail
is going to check if that domain voxcom
has a D mark record and we do thankfully
Vox took the time to set up a de mark
record which basically does three things
first it says that the email has to come
from a certain set of IP addresses that
Vox trusts second it says that the email
has to carry a unique signature that
only Vox can create and third it says
that if the email fails either of those
two tests then the email service
receiving the email should reject it
should just throw it away so that it
never reaches anybody's inbox because of
that my Vox email address your box email
address we can't be easily impersonated
okay so say an email comes in from a
domain that doesn't have a D Marc record
or has set their d mark policy to
something other than reject that email
is going to have a higher chance of
getting through now the email providers
all have spam filters they have these
algorithms that are looking through
these emails to check and see if
anything's fishy but obviously that
didn't stop Dylan's fake email from
getting into my yahoo inbox I would
guess that the whu-oh does not have a
strong D mark policy set up if they have
one at all okay there's actually a way
that we can double-check this here's Vox
first oh nice it has this nice little
green box that comes up but this is the
actual D Marc record and the equals D
mark one P equals reject so this is
telling us that our policy is reject
this email and this is true also I think
of yeah the CDC as well what about the
White House yeah let me try the White
House huh okay so the White House has
published a Demark record but if you
look at it P equals none meaning that
they're not telling email providers to
reject emails that come from other IP
addresses or that generally are not from
their approved domain senders the weird
thing about that so this is their
guidance on what all federal agencies
are supposed to do all agencies are
required to within one year after
issuance of this directive set a Demark
policy of reject
second-level domains and mail signing
hosts so the white house is violating
its own policy at the very least they're
acknowledging that a Demark policy
overjack is the strongest protection and
it is very clear that they are not using
that protection so now let's try this wh
Oh Oh
impersonation attacks they have not
published a Demark record at all and I
can understand like the w-h-o has a lot
on their hands right now they're
basically leading the global effort
against this giant pandemic but damn it
really seems like they should have done
this yeah although to be fair it's not
like the WHI was alone in this there's
this report by Bali mail that shows that
less than 15% of domains with D mark
have actually set their policy to reject
spoofed emails or send them to spam
there's kind of an incentive issue at
play which is that you publish the
record to protect other people from
being phished and the trade-off there is
that if you don't configure it properly
and it does take some work to set up
correctly you risk some of your emails
not being delivered I think that the
w-h-o is in a tough spot
right now because it is incredibly
important in this moment that their
emails get through and also there's an
increase in the risk that it's coming
from a fake domain and that you know
maybe they have some more responsibility
than they might have before in terms of
protecting people from fake emails yeah
hey do it for us cuz we're all you know
vulnerable out here yeah I think for
information it is the sort of thing that
every good citizen of the Internet
should do but like eating your
vegetables and working out every day
it's not something that every
organization does
you
you